[موسيقى
] عرض للتحدي والطموح العسكري
من قوات ديكتاتور كوريا الشمالية الشاب
كيم جونغ أون ،
اختبرت للتو نوعًا جديدًا من
صواريخ كروز بعيدة المدى وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية في كوريا الشمالية التي نشرت
صورًا لصاروخ ينطلق من صاروخ  قاذفة متنقلة
وصاروخ في منتصف الرحلة ،
ادعى الكوريون الشماليون أن الصواريخ حلقت
لأكثر من ساعتين في شكل بيضاوي وشكل
ثمانية أنماط وسقطت في البحر على بعد
أكثر من 900 ميل ،
يقول الخبراء إن صواريخ كروز هذه لا يمكنها
الوصول إلى الولايات المتحدة القارية ولكنها
تشكل  خطر مع ذلك ، ما
يعنيه ذلك هو جلب وتحمل
القوات الأمريكية وحلفائنا في اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبية وجميع أنواع الأماكن الأخرى ، لذا
علينا الآن أن نقلق بشأن كوريا الشمالية
التي لديها نعم الصواريخ الباليستية ولكن
أيضًا الطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ كروز
وكل ما تم إضافته معًا هو
هجوم معقد ومتكامل
حيث يمكن أن يأتوا من جميع
الاتجاهات المختلفة وجميع أنواع المسارات
والارتفاعات والعيوب.
تنظيم هجوم أكثر تعقيدًا للدفاع ضد اختبار صاروخ كروز يأتي بعد أيام قليلة من استعراض مذهل وغريب في منتصف الليل عبر ساحة كيم إيل سونغ في بيونغ يانغ ، ولا توجد صواريخ معروضة بدلاً من ذلك ، بدلاً من ذلك ، هناك فرقة من الكلاب ، وهي وحدة ترتدي بدلات برتقالية شديدة الخطورة وصورة أذهل المحللون أن كيم جونغ أون يبدو أنحف بشكل لافت للنظر عما كان عليه قبل بضعة أشهر فقط ، هل من مصلحة كوريا الشمالية حقًا أن تُظهر لبقية العالم أن كيم جونغ أون يتخلص من الوزن ، وإذا كان هذا قد علمك بالمشكلات الصحية ، فكيف هل ستتولى كوريا الشمالية إدارة الخلافة والاستقرار الداخلي وكل هذه القضايا الأخرى التي قد تكون مهمة بالنسبة لك تعرف أن دولًا مثل الولايات المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية تم عرض كيم حتى في لقطات دعائية يبدو أنها تستمتع بمشروب أخضر مشرق مع قشة ملتوية في كل جزء لما يبدو أنه عودة ظهور المرشد الأعلى على المسرح العالمي بعد ذروة جائحة الفيروس التاجي عندما أغلق بلدته  للجميع بما في ذلك
الصين وبعد القمم رفيعة المستوى التي
عقدها كيم مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كيم ، اختبر صواريخ باليستية أقصر مدى في
وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
اختبارات الصواريخ التي
يعتقد المحللون أنها يمكن أن تكون حسابًا من كيم
لتوجيه انتباه الرئيس بايدن في
طريقه.  فكر في
الأجواء الآن حيث
استهلكنا
الوباء جميعًا ، حيث شاركت الولايات المتحدة أيضًا
في الانسحاب من أفغانستان حتى
تعرف كوريا الشمالية أن الولايات المتحدة لا يمكنها
أن توليها الاهتمام الواجب لأنها
تريد أفضل شيء  يمكنه أن يفعل الآن
هو الاستمرار في وخز الإبرة
في جانبنا بشكل أساسي لتذكيرنا بأن
كوريا الشمالية لا تزال تمثل تهديدًا مستمرًا بينما
يقول المحللون إن عمليات إطلاق الصواريخ الأخيرة هذه
هي محاولة من قبل
الكوريين الشماليين لجذب انتباه إدارة بايدن
وهم قلقون أيضًا
أنه يمكن أن يكون جزءًا من
سباق تسلح متسارع مع كوريا
الجنوبية يمكن أن
يزداد سوءًا.  قدرة صاروخية بالأشعة تحت الحمراء
في الأسابيع الأخيرة بما في ذلك
اختبار صاروخ باليستي
أطلقته غواصة بريان تود سي إن إن واشنطن